virile vanishing relay VOR Lieberthal
long live the 25th of April long live
freedom the words of a former resistance
fighter during world war ii santa
Giovannetti
who stuck at home in the Italian capital
Rome the nationwide lockdown means on
the 75th anniversary of liberation day
marking the end of fascism they're
hanging flags from their windows up and
down the country instead of holding
parades and for 196 year old former
parties and who fought Mussolini's
forces that's heartening and amia
right now the pandemic is more important
in anti-fascist demonstrations but we
must also keep them alive especially at
this time because at this moment we
might destroy everything of the Italian
democratic state in the name of a
pandemic that is very dangerous and very
uncertain it's that uncertainty that's
behind Belgium's approach as it plans to
gradually lift restrictions despite
having the highest coronavirus death
rate per capita in Europe from the 4th
of May when the first shops reopen
everyone age 12 or over will have to
wear a mask on public transports the
government's probably seem to help the
federal government's and the different
entities are implementing a common
strategy to guarantee that every citizen
will receive for free at least one
protective mask covering both the mouth
and the nose bars and restaurants across
Belgium will start reopening in June but
the government says it will bring back
restrictions if the medical situation
worsens it's not an easy question can we
release everything no I don't think so
because I think then we will have a huge
problem here on the intensive-care but
are almost full in Britain where the
number of people recorded as dying in
hospital from covered 19 has gone past
20000 people are being urged to be
patient and stick to the stay home
guidelines the five tests we have laid
out must be met before we can ease these
life-saving restrictions we must be sure
that we can continue to protect the NHS
that there is a sustained
and consistent fall in the daily rates
of death that the data shows the rate of
infection decreases that the operational
challenges are met and of course that
there is no risk of a second peak of
infections meanwhile in the French
capital where restrictions are even
tougher this neighborhood cinema is
projecting films onto its walls for
anyone living near enough a simple way
of bringing people together until
they're allowed to socialize once again
the Dean barber al Jazeera